Well, I wanted to begin with
just a housekeeping item,
which is that next Monday we'll have a,
the last class if you
want to call it that,
but it will be completely different
in that it will be a review session.
I'll elaborate on what
format that might take,
but essentially I'll be count,
there won't be anything that I'm planning
to lecture about. On the contrary,
it will be your opportunity to raise
questions or make comments on, uh,
any aspects of the material
that you wish to discuss more.
So, uh, the format will be that
there'll be a microphone and uh,
you'll come up and use it and
ask questions and then, uh,
we'll discuss anything that you wish.
So it will really be,
I'll be in your hands and that
will be a glass that will, uh,
would be helpful if you came with things
that you wanted to discuss or things
that you think that we
should, uh, go into more.
So that will be what we'll do
on Monday for today. Instead,
we're going to talk about a three.
In fact,
new diseases that are um,
demonstrated once more that
the post World War Two idea,
the complacent assumption.
Dot.
Modern medical science and public health
had the tools to protect society and to
eradicate diseases one
by one when not illusion.
A fostered by the example of smallpox and
nearly by the eradication of polio was
once again punctured and as it had been
earlier by the emergence of HIV AIDS,
most of all, it showed that our
society is still vulnerable,
particularly to respiratory
infections in the industrial world,
transmitted by air or droplets.
They're true diseases of
globalization and maternity,
the thrive on high population density
and modern means of high speed
communication.
So I want to end our semester
by talking about SARS,
avian flu and swine flu and some of
the lessons we've learned from those
experiences.
I would regard them as the first new
diseases of the 21st century and also as
our great dress rehearsals for something
much more serious that may or may not
come later. Once again, I don't
want to make a prediction.
So let's begin with SARS.
The first great dress
rehearsal of the 20th century.
As you know,
or remember it began in November,
2002 with an index case,
uh,
from someone from the Quandong province
in southern China as severe and unusual
pneumonia.
What took place then in China was not
something an ex that was extraordinary as
our press tried to persuade us.
Rather,
it was something that's
happened many times,
the emergence of a new pathogen
previously unknown only in the sixties and
seventies.
Was there a boundless optimism about the
capacity of modern medicine to prevent
that from happening again?
Once again,
we're reminded that the
natural world isn't static,
but in a state of constant
Darwinian evolution with
the consequence that they're
always and inevitably new and emerging
diseases and viruses as you know,
are specially capable of
sudden rapid mutation.
Well,
the media did us a disservice at the
outset of SARS with sensationalizing
headlines,
attempting to stir up fear.
Examples being is this the Big One?
Um, killer bugged and uh, the light,
the Chinese authorities and their
response to SARS practice to conspiracy of
silence at the outset,
producing no reports or statistics
and censoring the press.
This will remind you of what happened
in China that also concealment isn't
something we haven't counted before
encountered before and it'll remind you of
other examples of public
health by concealment. Now,
why we might speculate,
did the Chinese decide
to conceal this outbreak?
First we could say would be the fear
of applicant omic repercussions.
The world economy at the time was already
stagnant and there were fear of the
implications for vulnerable
sectors. Travel, tourism,
investment.
There was a matter of national pride.
The World Health Organization had
already produced a report ranking world
healthcare systems and China had
ranked 144th just below Bangladesh.
So a medical emergency could cast a
new and harsh light on Chinese public
health.
It's also probably true that authoritarian
political systems have people who
man,
the op around us whose career
depends on producing good news.
We might also point to what we might
call an authoritarian paternalism.
The idea of sparing the population
anxiety and avoiding giving rise to
challenges to the state
and its priorities.
And then he case and whatever the
reasons China place the health of its own
citizens at risk by failing to enable
them to make informed decisions about
their own health.
And it took the risk also of allowing
the new disease to threaten the
international community,
delaying the process of patient detective
work that was required to unravel the
secrets of this new infection.
Finally,
on the 9th of February,
the Chinese Ministry of Health notified
the World Health Organization of some
305 cases and six municipalities
in southern China.
This too was a serious underestimate
and it was followed by weeks of tardy,
release of dubious and statistics that
were meant still to be reassuring.
So for weeks,
the World Health Organization wasn't
allowed to send teams of researchers to
investigate the disturbing
events in China.
The pathogen,
which is
this one was unknown.
The time of the outbreak was now known
to be a previously unincorporated corona
virus.
It structure was a schematic
picture of it would be that,
okay,
it's early names. Uh, what to call it.
It was called human pneumonia associated
corona virus because of one of its
early victims.
It was called the Urbani virus,
but the name that stuck was SARS,
severe acute respiratory syndrome.
Okay,
let's follow our usual procedure and
look at the symptoms and the epidemiology
and some of the effects on
society of the SARS outbreak.
In terms of symptoms,
the disease was first identified
and defined by Dr Carlo or bonding,
a 46 year old infectious disease expert
for the who who was working at an
annoying and once one of the early
physicians to encounter the disease.
He contracted it and died soon after.
The symptoms were an incubation
period of about a week,
five to 10 days or so,
followed by a sudden onset of fever
about to a hundred degrees to 101 general
malaise, headache, muscle pain, dizziness,
sore throat,
three to seven days later.
The majority of cases improve
spontaneously with no lasting ill effect,
but a minority of cases worsened at
that very point with lower respiratory
involvement.
And this led to a hacking,
nonproductive cough,
terrible shortness of
breath and chest pain.
It's worth remembering that the disease
at this stage was thoroughly unpleasant.
Uh,
Toronto nurse suffering from SARS was
interviewed by phone from her hospital
room and she said that the cough she
was experiencing was so violent that she
turned blue and it caused her to fall
to our knees and a minority of cases.
There was a progress to very severe
respiratory distress requiring oxygen and
mechanical support.
Rays revealed what was
called atypical pneumonia,
which was a somewhat confusing term
because it had been used that until that
time for a different condition.
On the 7th of May,
2003 the World Health
Organization suggested that
SARS had a case fatality rate
of about 15% or so.
There was no known specific treatment
and patients were given broad spectrum
antibiotics and antivirals,
but they weren't very effective and
treatment was really symptomatic and
supportive.
What about transmission?
The dominant mode for transmitting
SARS was clearly face to face contact
droplets from coughing or sneezing
and the droplets were inhaled or the
contaminated objects that is fun.
Mites and the person touching them and
then bringing the hand to the mouth could
ingest the virus.
This mode of transmission was encouraging
for public health because it meant
that the disease required prolonged
contact at close range and was much less
contagious than say the Spanish influenza,
smallpox or pneumonic plague and the
dominant pattern of the epidemic was for
SARS just spread in tight clusters of
people closely gathered around a patient
healthcare personnel, their
family members, hospital visitors,
guests on the same floor of a hotel or
residents of the same wing of an urban
tenement dwelling and the disease like
airborne viral infections in general
seems to be an equal opportunity
affliction that can pass to all classes of
society, the young, the old,
the healthy and those with
preexisting conditions,
but there also was some evidence,
although mostly remained confined
to the hospital environment,
at least outside of China,
it could spread to communities.
There were speculations during the
outbreak of people who were called super
spreaders,
sort of viral.
Typhoid Marys was the
image who are unusually,
very [inaudible].
The new shed viruses inhaled
at a greater distance,
perhaps through the air
conditioning system of a hotel
or the circulating air of
an airplane.
There was speculation that sometimes
it could spread through the fecal oral
route or through asymptomatic carriers.
In any case,
the disease spread from southern China
and Kwang Dong province to its next
epicenter,
which was Hong Kong,
which was particularly important because
of population density and mass air
travel.
Hong Kong being one of the great hubs
of the international air travel network.
The,
it's important noting too
that Hong Kong had intense,
constant links with neighboring
southern China in sheer size.
It had some 6 million people and was
known as one of the most densely crowded
cities on earth and possess
the busiest airport in Asia.
The first outbreak was,
uh,
the Metropole Hotel in Hong Kong
and then very rapidly thereafter,
the Prince of Wales Hospital,
the disease at the initial initial cases
wasn't really recognized and no special
precautionary measures were taken though
the hospital and the hotel soon became
world famous as the first Pho sigh of
infection outside of Kwang Dong promised
the people afflicted early
on were doctors and nurses,
orderlies attendance,
hospital visitors,
and a couple of guests at the hotel.
So Hong Kong became the second world
epicentre epicentre and the disease spread
from there using air travel as its means,
it went to three places,
particularly.
First was to annoy in Vietnam,
then to Singapore,
and then on to this continent to Toronto.
It struck Toronto through a 78 year old
immigrant from Hong Kong who had been
staying at their Metropol hotel
before returning to Toronto.
She was hospitalized and died,
um,
and the Scarborough Hospital in Toronto.
There was soon a joke
about, um, uh, about SARS.
Uh, that is to say, uh, are you
worried about terrorists? I'm, no,
we're worried about Canadians.
Uh, and then he case, uh,
what was that? What were the public
health measures that were adopted?
Uh,
first thing is to note that I've said
this was a great dress rehearsal and it
was a transformative event.
Although we're going to see that all
of these three pandemics that were
discussed this morning were relatively
limited in terms of their impact.
They are really important for our
consideration because they marked a real
change in public health.
One of the few factors was that SARS
led to an unprecedented coordination of
international public health responses.
What happened was really extraordinary.
As Julie Gerberding,
the director of the CDC pointed out
saying that this was a monumental
international transformation that
what happened on the 12th of March,
the World Health Organization issued
a global alert by the 15th a travel
advisory and thereafter some 11
laboratories in 19 countries were linked
electronically.
As they shared all information and
real time hunting for the pathogen,
they began genetic sequencing and began
work attempting to find a vaccine and a
reliable diagnostic test.
The role exalt was success
in world record time.
On April 16 the World Health Organization
laboratory network announced that it
had identified the pathogen responsible
for SARS on by the 26th of March,
there was the beginning of electronic
ground rent ground rounds in which the
intranet was used to bring together d
clinicians from 13 countries to share
information on the care and
maintenance of SARS patients.
Those were novel features.
In addition,
there were some traditional measures that
were taken that constitute in part or
review of things that you're
already well familiar with.
A team of World Health Organization.
Epidemiologists began investigating the
epidemic in southern China and it's not
where spread some airports
began to quarantine.
People who arrive,
they took their temperatures,
examined them for symptoms and gave them
advisory cards with information on what
to do if they fell ill.
Hospitals set up isolation wards with
the capacity to contain air and with
barrier protection for hospital personnel,
double gowns,
facemasks goggles,
gloves and disinfection,
changes of shoes in affected areas.
There was the rigorous tracking
of all contacts, have known cases,
there was quarantine, uh, in some places,
even house arrests with video cameras,
unannounced,
police visits, sanctions,
fines and all the rest.
And you might like to know that the
Toronto Star also record mended reading
material for those in quarantine and it
looked a little bit like something that
might be a reading list for our course.
Uh,
that is the most popular view
book for the SARS patients.
You'll all be glad to know
was Daniel to fall journal.
If a plague gear and they also
read Khumbu and Boccaccio,
um, uh, in their quarantine in Toronto,
there was public information in the
media and on the web enabling citizens to
make rational public health choices.
There was compulsory masking,
the closing of schools,
counselation of sports events and
other large gatherings of people.
All of those were measures
that were fairly traditional.
So what's striking is a kind
of contrast on the one hand,
the high tech end working out the
biology and epidemiology of SARS with
extraordinary rapid,
efficient and high tech interventions.
On the other hand,
public health measures and
treatment were rather old fashioned,
low tech and traditional,
but the public health measures
were effective by mid May.
There were signs that the outbreaks
were retreating and being successfully
contained and healthcare settings.
By June 18th,
as the global epidemic
reached its hundredth day,
the number of cases was down to a handful.
On the 5th of July,
the World Health Organization announced
that stars had been controlled
worldwide.
The total by the end was something like
8,000 cases and a few hundred deaths.
Nonetheless, the passage of
this mark to transformation,
as I said in international public
health inter connectedness,
it also left behind it.
Uh,
important effects on communities.
Hong Kong was described as a ghost town.
It's shops,
restaurants, theaters, churches,
public health, transport.
We're all deserted.
And many closed communion
wasn't administered in
churches and daily life was
transformed for those in quarantine
and for healthcare personnel.
A joke circulated in Hong Kong that
if you wanted space to yourself,
all you had to do is sneeze and
you'd immediately be left alone.
There was economic impact,
the collapse of tourism
and the retail industry.
One estimate was that some $10 billion
were lost in Asia because of the impact
of SARS with knock on effects on
unemployment and fragile economic growth.
Toronto,
this epicenter in North America
was less severely affected,
but there were things there too that
reminders of parts of our course that you
now know very well.
There were reports in the city
that it was being seized by a SARS,
pounding the stigmatization
of victims and scapegoating.
A nurse who had been hospitalized and
later interviewed in the press reported
that a crowd had gathered
outside her home and stoned it,
or there was in the Canadian press a
series of reports on what was called SARS.
Racism,
particularly in China Town and children
of Asian origin were bullied in school
and Asian Canadians were shunned and
public Toronto also spawned reports of a
general fear.
Polls show that 60% of Canadians we're
worried or very worried about contracting
source and even places not
touched by the disease experience.
Some ripple shock effects.
Los Angeles and San Francisco had people
reported that surgical masks had been
sold out.
Ers and primary care physicians
were overwhelmed with
people with coughs and the
common cold Chinese restaurants and China
towns in the United States in various
cities were deserted.
And Health Canada reported an outbreak
of what it turned SARS racism against the
Asian community.
So the experience of SARS was the first
dress rehearsal of the 21st century for
emerging diseases.
And I think it showed that the world
community was still vulnerable,
especially to airborne diseases.
SARS tested the preparedness of public
health and the preparedness of political
authorities.
On the positive side,
it revealed and stimulated
an extraordinary technical
and scientific capacity
and interlocking laboratories that
identified the pathogen and in the ground
rounds in cyberspace.
But I would argue that there
wasn't really room for complacency.
The world was lucky and dodged a bullet
with SARS for a variety of fortuitous
circumstances.
The disease spread by droplets isn't
really very readily transmissible.
The chronology was fortunate.
The disease began to spread globally
in the spring, which is, you know,
is normally the beginning of the
end of the flu season and there was
serendipity.
The disease spread to Hong Kong,
Singapore and Toronto,
and those were all places with highly
developed healthcare systems and resources
making containment possible.
One wonders what the
result might have been had.
The earlier travelers who spread SARS
go to different destinations in resource
poor third world cities.
So that was the first dress rehearsal.
The second followed fairly quickly after,
and this was avian influenza,
h five and one which was a
new or emerging epizootic.
It was first isolated in 1996 but began
as a disease of waterfowl in Southeast
Asia in mid 2003 early cases were
mostly undetected and unreported.
There then followed three small waves
of this influenza outbreak beginning in
December,
2003 January,
2004 in Korea, Vietnam, Japan, Cambodia,
Indonesia first among susceptible birds.
It's spread rapidly and affected their
internal organs with a mortality rate of
nearly a hundred percent.
And this was one of the great global
epizootic with tens of millions of wild
birds perishing.
Then h five and one demonstrated that
it was capable of transmission to human
beings who came into contact
with infected poultry butchers,
people who res life pulse rate or
live in close contact with them.
Um, this is, oh,
that's the masking from SARS,
but I wanted to show you someone
at risk during the epidemic of,
um,
avian flu.
Then there was,
there were human cases that began a
second detected wave in June and July,
2004 that ended in November,
2004 and a third wave
beginning in December,
2004 again in Southeast Asia.
Once again,
if we look at,
uh,
I wanted to show you a few cases of
humor generated by the Asian flu.
Uh, we hear, we see a person
saying that they're safe at last,
but in fact they weren't really,
uh,
then there's this one which might take
you a second to see what's happened to
our friend Donald Duck.
Uh,
I think it's worth knowing that epidemic
diseases sometimes also generate a
human response through a,
and then there's this one that
I was particularly fond of, uh,
which is, uh, uh, your
flock of geese and of, um,
you know,
poultry with one sneezing in the back
and someone in the front sang very funny.
Uh, in any case, uh,
the spread was by
migratory birds in flight,
but also by the great trade
routes of the poultry industry.
Uh, the trade and chickens and
feathers and chicken parts, uh,
for USAS feed chicken excrement
for use as fertilizer.
Once again,
the world was fortunate in that avian
flu didn't spread readily among human
beings.
We then experienced our
third rehearsal for the 21st,
and this was swine flu
that all of you know,
h one n one.
It first appeared in Mexico in March,
April of 2009 as far as is known then
swept the globe and isn't in fact,
um,
hasn't entirely EBD as we
meet this morning thus far.
However,
apart from the early phase of the
disease in Mexico where it was,
um, fairly wild, it has been,
it was fairly serious in Mexico.
It's been elsewhere,
a widespread but relatively mild disease
that's infected millions and millions
of people.
But with a strictly limited mortality,
I'm mortality less even
than seasonal influenza.
But we need to remember that we
don't know the end of this story yet.
Um, it's viruses, uh,
for influenza are highly
unstable and capable of mutating.
And so it could achieve still a greater,
very elements.
And we know from previous outbreaks of
influenza that it could return in future
waves.
Often a powder of influenza outbreaks
has been to have the series of waves.
We don't know what will
happen with the swine flu.
This was the first epidemic disease.
However,
and this was a major transformation in
public health to appear after the entry
into force of the new international health
regulations of 2005 that were signed
by 194 nations including all members
of the World Health Organization.
Those regulations were intended to
provide rapid international response to
public health threats and in particular
the old regulations had declared that
there needed to be reporting only
for diseases that were already known.
It seemed to assume a static world
without the emergence of new diseases.
The new regulations took that into account
and called for compulsory reporting
of disease events of known diseases,
but also new ones,
new public health threats and the new
regulations than required reporting.
They standardized and improved intern
national surveillance and they allowed
World Health Organization intervention
through regularized procedures and they
played the new regulations and important
role in the unfolding pandemic.
Indeed,
the coordination of the international
response to swine flu at every level was
one of the most encouraging lessons of
this particular pandemic along with the
speed with which a vaccine was developed
and distributed along with antiviral
medications.
But once again,
there was no real place for complacency.
It was true and this was a worrying sign
that the disease took the world public
health community by surprise.
The ruling Dogma and matters of influenza
was not the next threat would emerge
in the far east and it was there
that surveillance was concentrated,
but this was a pandemic that surprised
everyone by breaking out first of all in
Mexico and it did so at a time that no
one was expecting in the spring rather
than in the early fall or winter
as influenza normally does.
The crisis also exposed a lack of
capacity in the public health system,
limited surge capacity in terms
of hospital beds or caregivers.
There was an ongoing public distrust of
vaccination as something dangerous there
was.
It also showed the capacity of airborne
respiratory disease to emerge without
warning and to spread rapidly across
the globe before vaccines could be
developed to contain them and as
in the case of SARS and avian flu,
so to h one n one show that the world
community was fortunate because this
turned out really to be addressed.
Rehearsal in the pathogen
had a very limited virulence.
So as a society,
how prepared war we
once a pandemic strain appeared,
it took quite a bit of time.
I think we should say that neither
doomsday pessimism nor complacency or
rational,
the threat is real,
but pessimism is also unrealistic and
there are many steps that could be taken
to contain the threat.
The SARS lesson showed us that virologists
can now be instantly linked via the
web along round the globe,
and that clinicians can
exchange information on patient
care in the same manner.
SARS was epic making in this organized
response and this process was
strengthened through avian flu and
swine flu especially important,
as I've said,
was the entry into force of the new set
of international health regulations and
individual communities and countries now
put into place advanced planning after
SARS with procedures before the
next emergency globalization
and other words was
not only a health risk,
but also a resource.
And you can see the difference
right here on our campus.
SARS,
I would argue,
caught Yale unprepared and
the result was confusion,
fear and delay.
By the time of the swine flu outbreak.
However,
the lesson had been learned and it was
very impressive to know that this time
around there was a coherent strategy that
everyone was kept informed throughout
the course of events and perhaps the
only worrying aspect was something that
wasn't our community's fault,
but it's sobering global issue.
It was worth remembering that last fall
at the height of the swine outbreak,
vaccines arrived just as the disease
was moving on from the state of
Connecticut.
In any case,
in the absence of an effective
therapy or prophylactic for patients,
supportive care and nursing are crucial
considerations and one could argue that
perhaps for profit medicine has squeezed
the surge capacity out of our system
and radically reduced the
ratio of nurses to patients.
There was also a crucially
important factor,
which was the race to develop a vaccine
and here to cultivate the virus in the
case, for example, of SARS,
massive numbers of ha or avian flu.
What was discovered was the need
for massive numbers of hen eggs.
And so the poultry industry should
perhaps have been declared of crucial
importance because the hens themselves
were needed for the vaccine,
but with parish and crippling numbers
in the event of the avian flu going
further,
communities also learned that they
could plan their response in advance.
They could take measures
to educate about coughing,
sneezing, etiquette, hand
sanitizing, the danger of fomites,
the utility of masking and the utility
of avoiding assemblies of people.
And as far as possible to isolate
themselves during the outbreak and the
importance of information to
prevent the spread of panic.
So I would argue that these three,
um,
dress rehearsals for the
21st century had major are,
although all three were in terms
of their impact as diseases,
they were very limited.
The world was fortunate in that respect.
They revealed important vulnerabilities,
but they also provoked a new organization
of a response through laboratories,
a new coordination of the
public health community, new,
uh,
awareness of the need rapidly to
distribute a and t virals and vaccines.
And they taught the necessity
of preparation in advance.
For the next outbreak.
So I would say that the world moved
on enormously as a result of SARS,
of avian flu and swine flu.
But I would argue that emerging diseases
are an inherent part of the human
condition.
Nothing totally to be thought
of as unexpected or strange.
And, uh, if I were to
make just one prediction,
I would expect that there would be more
on that the system set in place and
improved by SARS,
avian flu and swine flu will be
tested again and our new century.
And with that,
I'll stop and we'll gather again on
Monday for a review session of everything
that we've covered in our course.
So the review should include
everything from the beginning, um,
down through the very end.
It's not meant to be limited
just to the first half,
but to the whole of the semester.